I want to jump to this story from the
telegraph hosted by Yahoo news World War
III is approaching fast and too few are
willing to admit why well the article is
very interesting it does mention that
there was a drone attack a drone attack
on a US base near Jordan but it mentions
the core reason is that authoritarian
regimes are failing Iran Russia for
instance struggling to keep themselves
afloat are going to start making moves I
think it's actually a really good
argument faced with an existential
crisis either econ ically due to
population collapse or otherwise look a
drowning person is not they thrash about
violently and you know they say when
you're going to rescue someone who's
drowning you have to approach them from
from behind otherwise they drag you down
with them for for these countries that
are facing existential crisis and that
includes the United States there's an
option go to war and we've seen it time
and time again and uh there's a lot of
parallels to everyone's favorite Empire
the the Roman Empire but I want to point
out a few very important things the
world socialist website you know we love
them they report British Army Chief
issues call for conscription and of and
whole of n Nation mobilization for war
it's not just Britain Sweden has issued
a call for their sta for their citizens
to prepare for war and there have been
reports that people have begun signing
up to be conscripted so in Sweden they
have a system where you f out a
questionnaire and determine whether or
not you will be forced to join the war
effort brance 2 says Sweden's call for
population to prepare for war Sparks
panic and criticism now I don't consider
the world socialist website to be all
that credible but here's the interesting
thing I believe conscription is the
appropriate word based on the facts
corporate news doesn't want to say
conscription because of what it means to
the average person so of course the
times.co.uk says UK must train citizens
for war with Russia says Army
Chief let me just let me just try that
one for you again UK must train citizens
for war with Russia in other words
citizens should prepare to be
conscripted into war the times doesn't
want to say it corporate press doesn't
want to publicly State we will conscript
you and force you to go to war because
that is never popular and I believe if
all the big Outlets said right now
Sweden and the UK have issued calls for
conscription then there would be a major
push against escalation escal escalation
to stop the war so they want to keep
that out of sight out of mind but in the
end for those that are here in the
United States if Joe Biden decides
tonight to uh issue a retaliatory strike
on say the coast of Iran or something on
specific targets and he says for too
long Iran has been supplying the houthi
rebels and other militia groups in Iraq
and Syria and this is now resulted in
the death of three American citizens
America will retaliate we will not back
down if he strikes Iran and Iran says
we're going to war and then calls in
their allies and this escalates
dramatically do not be surprised if they
start sending out draft orders I have
unfortunately a son of draft age and
when I say unfortunately I don't it's
not unfortunate I have a son I like son
draft it's unfortunate that he is draft
age and it is it is as a father not
something that I want to see happening
obviously but in my entire life though
I've always grown up always thinking
that if we're attacked if our assets are
attacked overseas that we must r
retaliate the problem today is I don't
believe anything anymore I don't believe
anything I mean and and and when we
start we start talking about
conscription in Sweden or or especially
in the UK it's like Orwell spinning
around going I Told You So Told You So I
love I love my father but I remember
that one of the first big fights we had
I was maybe 11 or 12 we were watching
some war footage on TV and I told him uh
I will never be drafted they'll draft
they'll try and I'll never fight those
Wars I don't know just felt inherent to
my soul he he got really mad like how
dare you not want to protect your your
country and stuff but my dad buys into a
lot of like the corporate press although
watching Fox 5 and stuff he buys into
the that whole you know Narrative of
patriotism and he's from an older
generation and I get it and I get why he
was mad I always thought about that
fight but I I believe a double down on
that feeling I had then more now more
but you know what it's sad isn't it that
there used to be a generation of people
who said I believe in my country
wholeheartedly I will fight for them but
the problem is we have seen time and
time again the military-industrial
complex and special interests send young
men mostly men off to
for no reason other than their bottom
line yeah and I and I should add to that
because of what Tim just said I grew up
next to a military base seeing basically
people who are my surrogate brothers and
sisters older brothers and sisters who
were Cadets come back with no limbs
going to die for Wars that made no sense
you know so I that was the world I was
born up into and it made no absolutely
no sense to yeah this is the
conversation my family had when my
brother enlisted and when he he deployed
to Afghanistan with the Marine Corps was
like but why are we here like you know I
respect that that was the path he
thought was right for him and you know
everything else but also is this the the
the operation that I think is most value
for your time not to mention all the
risk but all all service members
families are going to worry about the
risk it was like we don't even need to
be here yeah and you're going anyways
risk is important and we should be you
know and the military to some degree can
be important uh but what has become the
the industrial complex that eisenh how
are warned about we are living in that
horrible nightmare right now if we can't
clearly Define that that the answer to
that question why are we here why are we
going that's why have to have Congress
make these decisions and not
unilaterally made by one decrepit old
scile man or whoever's going wow I
usually call him a reanimated corpse
you're very very nice to sorry well it's
because I'm much closer to his age than
you are you you are doing way better
than that man is man I put in quotes
that's the thing too Trump and Biden are
not so far off in age and there's
obviously a huge difference between I
mean there are other politicians that
are close to bider age and he is just
not doing well at a certain point you
have to just you feel unkind being like
you are are falling apart sir but you
really are we we got a funny Super Chat
Mory says jenz is not fighting for this
country
LOLOL here's a Here's a thought excuse
me sir I noticed that you just illegally
crossed the border would you like to be
a citizen of this country here's a gun
we're sending you to Ukraine the
likelihood I think is is actually very
fairly great in the event of a major war
that the US look it used to be I love I
love the history of of rifling there
used to be oh I love the story of like
The Last Samurai in Japan they were
considered high ranking high class High
status trained Warriors and then we
bring them rifles and we're like you
don't need to train anybody you just
hand it to them you tell them to point
and shoot and all of a sudden the
samurai are considered the much much
less important you don't need to train
someone from birth to be a fighter
anymore when you can hand a gun to
somebody yeah so I don't think people
realize that with with all these
migrants coming through the Border you
doesn't care at all if they're like if
we can bring in 6 million people every
all the people on the right keep saying
military age males yeah congratulations
the US government says we got 6 million
military age males and we'll tell them
you have no choice you are fighting on
our behalf the question is is what
direction are they going to point the
gun doesn't matter literally literally
does not matter you you you you just
drop Six you you start transporting
these people in Mass to an enemy nation
and it's bedum for that country no
matter what I mean you look at what's
happening in the United States because
of it these people sleeping in airports
the conflict the cast this is not even
conf it's just them literally being
there causing problems you look at the
United States saying we're going to give
you weapons you win that war you're a c
citizen of the United States a bunch are
going to say you got it boss but even if
they don't just sending them over to
Iran or whatever it's going to cause
chaos sounds like the Roman Empire to me
yeah and to me the question is like if
they are then back here and they're like
yes thank you government you gave me my
citizenship and I can fire a gun and
they're like now attack fellow citizens
because we said so the loyalty is
concerned me I actually thought you were
going to go a different direction which
is like I would be fine to send our
military to our Southern border to
defend it I don't know why go other
places I think the good news here is uh
uh if we do send a bunch of these
criminal aliens in the United States and
say you can be a citizen if you go fight
in Iran or whatever the good news is the
US doesn't keep its promise to its
veterans so once they come back they'll
be completely discarded and the right
won't have to worry about them becoming
citizens this is very Grim cast today
we're very Grim
cast yeah well you know it's hard not to
be when you're seeing this stuff in the
news you know what seeing this this
corpse about to announce more war it's
terrible no Mean Tweets that's right
thank God thank God I I just keep they
wer even really that mean come on I just
keep thinking about something to look
forward to every day I love that you
ever see the journalists when they were
like since Trump when when Trump uh when
Biden wins the White House they're like
I used to have to wake up at 3: in the
morning for my phone buzzing a tweet
from Donald Trump and my editors like
you have to write it up now and they're
like now he's gone and we don't or he
got banned we don't have to worry about
it anymore and it's it's finally I'm
relaxing just good old war that's all we
got to write about just have war no no
tweets at and I see these news these
news items and I think about the way
Biden talks and just how weak he is and
I'm afraid that this Administration is
going to want to overcompensate for his
weakness by doing something real crazy
uh in the next few days because who
knows going to hard hard on Iran you
know dropping lots of bombs just making
the people know this is why you should
vote for me I'm a strong man Joe Biden
has never said once in his life unless
he plagiarize it from someone else
obviously but I just seeing all of that
I I I am like
having flashbacks to um the day they
announced Biden winning and all the
people in New York City dancing in the
streets and popping champagne I see
Stephen Pinker dancing in his living
room on how happy he is and this is what
they got I think we will absolutely have
some serious mobilization this year I
don't know if I would call it World War
III I mean whatever you know World War I
is trending on Twitter and people are
keep keep saying that this move by Biden
could trigger it and there's there's
smarter and more prominent political
figures than me around the world saying
we're all already in it especially
because of this fine but I I got to say
it's an election year Joe Biden's in
trouble I would not be surprised if we
go to war with Iran I I think it's in
fact I think it's greater than chance
does wartime presidents get reelected
yeah and and I wonder if that could
backfire on Joe Biden but I think it
outside of whether or not Biden could
get reelected the the Deep State
intelligence agencies and the military
military industrial complex are saying
if Donald Trump gets elected we ain't
getting our war go to War now then even
if Trump wins he can't back us out but
how bad does this world war have to be
before it's a greater threat to our
democracy than was January 6th I'm sorry
nothing on Earth could ever be more of a
threat than January 6th I don't even
know why you that was 10 911s yeah yeah
it was all of them unbelievable no and
that's a great point of like reading
these articles where that the US the UK
must train citizens for war how they can
downplay anything but also inflate like
something like January 6 into the wor
wor you know the way the politicians
talk about it it's it's D-Day it's Pearl
Harbor it's 911 uh but that's what they
do these are the tricks they play you
know the the death of language this is
what they constantly do it's it's it's
actually really scary because people so
many people still buy into it that's
exactly right yeah do you think people
will shift their opinion on Biden if he
were to take us into war do you think
that could help him get
reelected every single time we have this
situation with a president that's what
we expect is going to happen that's
where the you know the whole wack the
dog idea came from and I I just don't
know that first of all I don't know that
Biden is going to be there anyway I you
know I don't know what the I don't know
what the round table here uh consensus
is I'm saying he's not making it I don't
think because he's not going to make it
healthwise or they're going to pull him
oh he's they're going to pull him
they're going to have to pull him they
have no choice I mean just watch him
this past weekend he can't find his way
anywhere any longer all the signs are
there my father passed away as a result
of Alzheimer's and you know and I I'm
watching this unfold you know what we
saw in my own face family so it's not
going to happen he's not going to be
there but whoever's pulling his puppet
strings maybe that's what they need is
World War II yeah yeah I think it's I
think it's possible who's p puppet
strings I think their hope is look when
uh when we have Trump no new Wars time
lines for withdrawal Joe Biden gets in
what's the first thing he does revers
his course we get more troops we get
Syria uh troops in Syria being bolstered
and whoever remembers us declaring war
on Syria just what when when was that
when did we deploy I don't think we ever
declare war on anything get war in
Ukraine we get escalation with China
we've got strike us strike groups moving
through the straight of Taiwan you've
got Venezuela and Guyana it is bubbling
up and the the military
military-industrial complex guys are are
are
salivating but they may be thinking you
know Joe can't win Nikki Haley's in
their back pocket she says she's GNA
stay here until super Tuesday I could
not believe it I couldn't believe it I'm
I'm like we got a live event we're
planning in Virginia for super Tuesday
and I said let's be real it's not going
to be a super Tuesday I don't know what
it'll be and then she comes out and
she's like I'm not backing out until at
least then it's like okay lady but
that's their plan you got to get some
kind of warmongers up there but if they
can't win they'll take their consolation
prize war with Iran before Trump gets in
and there's nothing anyone we you can't
stop it Joe Biden's the president
republicans in Congress won't do
anything so literally the best course of
action is you vote for Trump and then
hope he can wind things down as quickly
as possible when he becomes president
they're going to pull Biden the
Democrats and replace him with uh Nikki
Haley that's what they're going to do
I'd be surprised wouldn't be surprised
how funny would that be that would be
funny I don't think she would actually
do it um she sounds a lot like them
it'll be interesting to see I mean this
is what I'm so interested with Joe
Mansion right now because he said I'm
not going to run for uh Senate again in
West Virginia and he's been in since
2010 which the other fact of this that I
love is that he got nominated or
appointed to the Senate after uh Senator
Robert bird died in off office at 96
after being in office for 51 years I
mean the West Virginia senate seat has
like just basically never been available
in American history uh but he his all
everything he's saying I mean he just
had this interview with CNN saying the
White House is controlled by far
far-left people and he said this a
couple times about Biden and so there
same with um Dean Phillips all of his
stuff if you look at his bio that he has
on his official um Congressional website
right now is like I am a moderate so
there is this movement within the party
to say like we are actually not like
them please don't lump Us in with the
rest of them thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net